so good to see you both congratulations
on this beautiful beautiful movie thank
you
I'm curious with Michael there on set
obviously as a um
a fantastic resource to be able to help
you guys find your characters and find
the details
is there a particular detail about the
relationship that you guys put on screen
or something about the character that
you're able to find that you're
particularly proud of maybe something
that you know when Michael saw it he
gave you his approval
um
you know I Michael said he's answered
this himself actually so I but I I just
repeat that but he the deck scene uh the
scene outside on their on their patio
where the the proposal happens towards
the end of the film and they're smoking
together he he really feels that that
best reflects the reality of how that
scene played out in real life the kind
of space around it and them just really
listening to each other and being in
that moment and um I I feel
like that was such a pleasure to be part
of that scene but also for me I think
something that I was really determined
to have in the filming which was in the
script anyway was their sense of
playfulness between their their
interplay and their playfulness as
characters and their kind of like
chemistry and banter and
um the wit that they have with each
other and uh we had to work really hard
um but I think I'm proud of that in the
film for sure
Jim what was it like for you working
with Ben like what was the first scene
that you actually did together and was
it something that was very easy to get
into
um well this is a complicated answer in
a way the first scene Ben and I did
together was the oncology appointment
where he gets the diagnosis of stage
four cancer so that was definitely trial
by fire and that seemed like a really
bad way to have to start that being said
the facts and emotional tonality of that
scene were so well documented in the
book by Michael that in some ways
while it was emotionally challenging it
wasn't difficult at all to get into
because there was like there's there's
such an amorphous quality to like a
first date scene and things like that
where it's like cat and mouse and things
like this was just Clarity uh harrowing
Clarity
um but that was our first that was our
first time together yeah
the the scenes over the holidays uh I I
love the interplay between the two of
you and the way you're setting up their
life together can you think of the most
thoughtful gift that someone has ever
given you over the holidays
our holidays
oh that's hard I was going to tell you
uh for me it wasn't a holiday gift
though so I'm sorry to say that but it
was when my husband threw me
um a party for my 40th birthday he said
I want a big party I was like I don't
and and yet he did it and it was so
special to be surrounded by so many
people at that at that monumentous
moment of 40.
um so that that wasn't a holiday gift
and I apologize it was more of a
springtime gift yeah I also I can't beat
that and I'm totally blanking on on
unthoughtful gifts even though I know
I've been given many so I've given you
several thoughts yeah no I know but I
know in December
all the gifts that Jim has given me ever
very good I love that I I have to say I
am very excited for people to see this
movie I got so emotional uh and it you
guys were both wonderful in it so